[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEROME MCFARLAND:
Hello, everyone.
Welcome to Implementing Scalable
Storage for Kubernetes on GCP--
Container Mobility
Requires Data Mobility.
I'm Jerome McFarland, VP
of marketing at Elastifile.
And I'm going to be joined today
by my co-presenter, Katreena
Mullican, technology
director and cloud whisperer
at the HudsonAlpha
Institute for Biotechnology.
In today's session,
we're going to be talking
about the critical relationship
between container orchestration
as facilitated by Kubernetes
and the underlying data
that many containerized
workflows need
to persist and manage.
Now as a framework
for this conversation,
I'm going to take you
through a simple use case
example involving web
services implemented
across a hybrid cloud.
And this example is going to let
us discuss and illustrate some
of the key considerations
around data management and data
mobility for these types
of containerized workflows.
Then Katreena's
going to join us.
And she's going to take
you through a different use
case in a demo, illustrating
how HudsonAlpha is leveraging
Kubernetes to manage
data-centric workflows
across hybrid clouds in the
scientific computing domain.
So by the end of
the session, you
will have gotten a flavor
for a fairly broad set
of different use
cases in this area.
So let's get to it.
So as a framework for the web
services use case example,
I want you to think about a
multi-platform advertising
campaign.
So in this advertising
campaign, we're
promoting a product
called ElastiFizz.
It's this naturally essence,
gluten-free, zero-calorie
beverage that Elastifile
has decided to put out.
Now, in an effort to promote
ElastiFizz and drive traffic
to our ElastiFizz website where
we take orders by the caseload,
we've decided to splurge
a bit and purchase
some commercial time during
the recent World Cup final.
Now, having high confidence
in our marketing team
and the effectiveness
of the commercials
that they're going to design,
we expect a massive influx
of traffic to our website as a
result of our new commercial.
So of course, we want
to maximize our ROI.
We want to get the
best bang for our buck,
so we need to make sure that our
web infrastructure supporting
our website can
scale effectively
to support this increase in
load, this increase in demand.
So that's the
challenge before us.
Now, this type of
a challenge, it's
a fairly common one
to many organizations
who are looking towards
the cloud as a way
to extend their IT.
They may have some
sort of bursty workload
or some increase in demand
that they're expecting,
and they want to leverage
elastic infrastructure
to be able to scale to
support that demand.
Of course, the cloud has
near-infinite elastic
resources, so it seems
like a perfect fit.
So we should just tie everything
together and make it all work,
right?
Should be simple.
Well, unfortunately,
as many of you
may have experienced
if you've tried
to implement these
kinds of workflows
in the past, the making it
work part hasn't necessarily
always been so easy, right?
In many cases,
especially when you're
dealing with data and the
considerations around data,
you may have found yourself
implementing isolated storage
islands in the cloud.
You may have found
yourself pushing data
into the cloud with manual
type of forklift migrations
to manage the data in the cloud.
You may have implemented
complex schemes
to copy data between
storage islands
in an effort to create some
semblance of synchronization
or data sharing, right?
Now of course, these
types of manual methods,
they definitely can work, but
they can be extremely painful.
Fortunately, with
what Kubernetes
has brought to the table,
and with the data management
technologies and techniques
that I'm going to be describing
and that we'll be demoing
today, implementing
these sorts of workflows
is easier than ever before.
Now, before we get into
the implementation and some
of the specifics
around that, I want
to take a quick step back
and see how we got here.
So as you all know, right--
no surprise-- containers
are everywhere.
At this conference, at
almost any conference
in this space, Kubernetes,
Docker containers
are on everyone's lips, right?
And that's been
the case, honestly,
for the past several years.
But the thing that's changed
more recently is many
workflows, core workflows, and
core use cases are now being
targeted for containerization
that previously may not have
been considered to be
a containerizable--
if I can make up that word--
type of a workflow, right?
Containers and
Kubernetes are no longer
the exclusive domain of
stateless applications
and freshly written
microservices.
People want to use them
for much, much more.
And Kubernetes
orchestration isn't just
making these expanded
use cases possible,
it's really making them easy.
And when you think about
these expanded use cases,
data is a big part
of them, right?
We all know that Kubernetes
and containerization
offers massive benefits for
packaging and mobilizing
applications.
And to extend those benefits
to core workflows that
involve data, you need a
persistent data management
layer, right?
You need something to be
able to store and manage data
beyond the lifecycle of a
given container or a given pod.
So these types of
solutions become
necessary as you extend the
scope of workflows and use
cases that you're
leveraging with containers.
Lots of different applications
have these requirements, right,
from examples that
involve web services,
like we'll discuss today,
to any kind of example that
persists or manages user
data, to a broad range
of industry-specific
applications and domains,
like scientific computing
for life sciences,
or financial services,
or media-entertainment.
And there's many,
many more examples.
Now fortunately,
Kubernetes, in anticipation
of these requirements,
has evolved
to supply services
that help you address
these data-centric requirements
and data-centric needs, right?
With Kubernetes
persistent volumes,
you can seamlessly
integrate data storage,
a persistent storage layer into
your Kubernetes deployments.
With Kubernetes
storage classes, you
can control and manage the
dynamic provisioning of storage
by leveraging Kubernetes
volume provisioners.
And with stateful sets,
you can manage the ordering
and management of certain
sets of pods or containers
within Kubernetes.
So with all of these
flexible capabilities
and integration options that
Kubernetes has given you,
you have a lot of
choices and options
for what to do on the data side.
So what should I deploy as
a data management layer?
What should it look like?
Should I be deploying
file storage?
Should I be targeting
block storage?
Should I be looking at
open-source solutions?
Should I be looking
at vended solutions?
So next, I'm going to go through
some of the key considerations,
at least in our
view, that we think
you should be taking into
account as you think about what
types of stateful services and
what kind of data management
layers and data
management platforms
you should be deploying.
And then I'll introduce you
to a qualifying solution
from Elastifile and taking
you through the demo flow
of our web services example.
So first key consideration--
and there's going to be four--
the first one that I want
to talk about is usability.
And when we think
about usability,
we're really talking
about ease of integration,
ease of adoption, ease of use.
And from the data management
and the storage perspective,
you're really talking about how
you interface with the data.
And so really, what kind
of storage are you using?
Are you using file storage,
using object storage,
using block storage?
And in our view, file
storage makes a lot of sense
as the default storage
platform and storage
interface for
stateful containers,
for persistent storage
implemented with Kubernetes,
because of the broad range
of applications and workflows
today that rely on a file
system and expect a file
system, right?
At last year's Next, in
one of the presentations,
Descartes Labs noted
that 90% of the calls
in the open-source GitHub
repository, the storage
interface calls, were
calling fopen, right?
So they were expecting a
POSIX-compliant file system
underneath.
And those was, by far, the
most prevalent type of storage
that was being called, more
than an order of magnitude
over any other type of
storage, including object.
So really, I think
file is the way to go.
In addition, of course, to
being application usable
and application
accessible, file systems
are also human usable
and human accessible.
You know, we're all
very familiar with file
and directory hierarchies,
what those mean,
how to traverse them.
So leveraging a file system
provides a high level
of usability in conjunction with
your containerized workflows.
Another key criteria to
consider is scalability, right?
As we all know, Kubernetes
offers amazing capabilities
for scaling application
deployments and scaling
your ability to
handle workloads.
So when you're implementing
a persistent storage layer,
you want to complement that.
You want to have
something that can
scale to support the
capacity and performance
requirements at
the storage level
to meet your needs of
today for your workflows,
as well as you're evolving these
as your workflows may scale.
Third key criteria is
shareability, right?
You want to get away from
dealing with storage islands,
right?
It's a problem.
It can create a lot of
complexity in data management.
So if you have a solution that
can allow you to share data
across your infrastructure--
so across your nodes,
across your storage devices--
and present single
namespaces that
can scale out, that provides
huge benefits to enable
seamless collaboration across
applications, across users,
and across workflows.
And the final key criteria
that I want to discuss
is around data mobility, right?
So as we all know, Kubernetes
provides extreme power
for application mobility, the
ability to package and mobilize
applications.
So having complementary
capability
to package and
mobilize your data
can be hugely beneficial,
especially when
we're talking about hybrid
workflows and the needs that
arise to take data
from on-premises
and be able to leverage and
access that data in the cloud.
So here are our
four key criteria.
And now I'm going to talk a
little bit about the Elastifile
solution-- and of course,
we feel that we meet these
criteria fairly well--
and give you a sense for
how you can leverage us
as we go through the demo flow.
So in a nutshell, the way
to think about Elastifile
is enterprise-grade, scalable,
POSIX-compliant file storage
for the cloud.
You can deploy us
in GCP Marketplace.
And essentially, we consist
of two key components.
One is the core file system
itself, the Elastifile Cloud
File System.
Or ECFS is what we
call it for short.
It's a software-defined,
scale-out, distributed file
system.
The other key component
of the Elastifile solution
is what we call
Elastifile CloudConnect.
And what CloudConnect
does is it delivers
data mobility between file
systems and object storage.
And it really allows you to
combine those two storage
paradigms to get the
best of both worlds.
And I'll go into a
little bit more detail
about how CloudConnect
comes into play
in these sorts of
containerized workflows
and across hybrid
clouds in just a moment.
But first, a bit about
the file system--
so ECFS, it's a software-only,
environment-agnostic file
system, right?
So you can run it in any cloud.
You can run it
on-premises as well.
And essentially, what it's
doing behind the scenes,
it's aggregating the storage
resources of your cloud VMs
and presenting them
to your applications
in a single shared namespace.
And what it delivers
to those applications
is POSIX-compliant
primary storage.
And when I say
primary source, I mean
this storage is meant for
applications, and workflows,
and users to interface
with directly, right?
It can support
transactional workloads.
And it's really
built for the cloud.
All of the services that
underlie the Elastifile
solution are distributed,
including the metadata
management.
As many of you who deal
with storage may know,
metadata management can
often become a bottleneck
to performance as
storage systems scale.
So our solution was
designed for the cloud.
And so the metadata
management model
was implemented in a
fully distributed fashion
to ensure that you
can scale effectively
with performance scaling
linearly as you scale out.
Now, to the user, what
Elastifile provides
is scalable capacity
and performance.
You have the ability
to add capacity
to your cluster in a hot
fashion and dynamic fashion
without bringing
the cluster down.
You can remove it if necessary.
And as I mentioned
before, performance
is going to scale out linearly
as you add capacity, as well.
Full enterprise
feature set, including
snapshots, data reduction
through compression,
deduplication high
availability, asynchronous
replication, et cetera.
Everything that you can do
with Elastifile through our GUI
and through our CLI is also
fully REST API controllable.
So you can implement
seamless workflows leveraging
infrastructure as code,
like Terraform or Ansible
as well with Elastifile.
And as I mentioned, it's
easily deployable at the push
of a button through
the GCP Marketplace.
So I'll just quickly show
you a quick deployment.
We're going to spin up an
Elastifile cluster here.
So we're going to call
this one Google Next Demo.
So you can do this
through Marketplace today.
You're going to select your
zone, some basic networking
information, and you're
going to hit Deploy.
Now what's actually
going to deploy here
is the Elastifile management VM.
That management VM is going
to give you access to our UI.
And from within our
UI, you're going
to be able to specify the
characteristics of the cluster,
the storage cluster that
you want to create, the most
important one, of course,
being the capacity
that you want to create.
So here we're logging
into the Elastifile UI.
So when that's done, you
can see our management
VM is up and running from
our management console there.
We're going to select the
type of storage that we want,
and we're going to add
9 terabytes of capacity
for this particular cluster.
In this case, that's going
to correspond to spinning up
three instances in GCP.
And if we go to the Compute
Engine, we'll be able to see.
You can see the management VM,
as well as those three storage
nodes that are going to
be part of our cluster.
They've all been started.
And so if we go back
to the Elastifile UI,
you'll be able to see
the deployment finishes.
And now you have a cluster
available with the capacity
that you specified.
So that's how easy it is, right?
You can just spin it up at
the click of a button, GCP,
put the capacity you want,
and we're up and running.
Now through that UI that you
just saw a preview of there,
you can do lots of other things.
You can manage capacity
and monitor capacity.
You can also manage and
monitor performance.
You can also look at the
status in your environment,
like the number of
nodes in your cluster,
the number of physical devices,
the number of connections,
et cetera.
You can also scale the cluster
through that same UI, right?
You saw us deploy it and
specify a certain capacity.
You can also scale it.
And we're continually
offering more and more options
for the types of storage and
the granularity of storage
that you can deploy in a
cluster to give you more options
to create the types of cost
and performance trade-offs
that you want in your
environments, right?
Even since the time when we
recorded that previous demo
clip, we've added
additional options
for adding capacity and
deployment capacity.
You can see here, we're
showing SSD persistent disks
and standard persistent disks.
You can also drill
down into performance.
You can look at it
at the high level.
You can also drill down
into certain time scales.
You can also look at
performance for certain--
call them collections of
data that we call Elastifile
file data containers
that are segments
of data within your file
system that you can choose
at your will, as desired.
And a data container
is something
that you can basically
configure with certain policies.
So you can say, for
this data container,
this collection of
files and directories,
I want compression to be on, or
I want deduplication to be on,
or I want both of them to be on.
And you can also set quotas.
So a way of managing
collections of data inside
of your contiguous file system.
And finally, you also
have this system view
that enables you to see the
health of your environment
on a continuous basis.
Now once you've got an
Elastifile file system spun up
in the cloud, you want to
leverage it with Kubernetes,
right?
So to connect it
into Kubernetes,
we've also just
released, just last week,
the Elastifile
storage provisioner,
also available through
GCP Marketplace.
And what the storage
provisioner does,
kind of calling back to
those Kubernetes functions
that I mentioned before,
it creates a storage class
for Elastifile
storage within GCP.
And through that storage
class, which you can see here,
you can connect a cluster.
And you can now specify
persistent volume claims
and persistent volumes that
leverage and deploy Elastifile
storage on a dynamic basis.
So now you have the ability to
connect in Elastifile simply
into any Kubernetes deployment
by leveraging this provisioner.
So if we go back to our
checklist really quick
and see how we're doing--
usability, file
interface, right?
We provide NFS file
storage, so we're
very user and
application-compatible.
It's POSIX-compliant.
And the key thing around POSIX
is the strict consistency.
So if an application writes
data to our shared namespace,
and another application
tries to read data,
the application
that's reading is
going to get the latest data
that was written, right?
It's strictly consistent.
Fully REST API-controlled,
as I mentioned before.
And we have a Kubernetes
volume provisioner
available in the Marketplace.
So I think we're
doing OK on usability.
Scalability, as I
mentioned, fully
distributed metadata model.
So it allows you to scale
out with linear performance
scaling.
You can add capacity, remove
capacity as necessary--
so highly elastic.
Shareability-- again,
it's a shared file system,
so you're unifying
all these resources
within a single namespace.
So all VMs, all pods, all
users can access the same data
regardless of where
they're connecting in
from the file space.
So the one piece that we
haven't talked about yet
is the data mobility piece.
And that's where
CloudConnect comes into play.
So as I mentioned, CloudConnect
manages the transfer
between file and object.
And it's a bidirectional
transfer that it can manage.
And it really blends the best
of both worlds in use cases
that involve both hybrid data
management-- so from on-prem
to cloud-- and also
in-cloud data management
between object and file.
So the thing to understand
about CloudConnect
is, really, what it's doing
is it's helping you to encode
the data of any given file
system into object storage
so that it can be stored
there in an inactive state
until you're ready to use it.
And then when you're
ready to use it,
you can pull the data out
again, using CloudConnect,
into another file system.
So in a hybrid mode, like
what I'm highlighting here,
what we would do is you can
start with data on-prem,
from any on-premesis
file system.
It doesn't have to be
Elastifile, but it could be.
What CloudConnect will do is
it will compress the data.
It will dedup the data.
It will encode the data
into object storage format--
so in this case,
into a GCS bucket.
And we're going to retain
all the file and directory
hierarchy information, all
the attributes, all the links,
everything about
the file system,
but encoded into object format.
Then when you're ready to
use that data in the cloud
and processes it natively
in your file system
in your primary
storage, CloudConnect
can also allow you to
then check out the data.
So putting it from file
to object is the check-in.
You can also check out
the data from object
to file and put it into
an Elastifile file system
that you're running
in the cloud.
You don't have to pull
out the whole namespace.
You can pull out certain
files, directories.
Up to you what you
want to pull out.
So again, we try to be very
efficient about how we transfer
the data, because that
can be a painful component
for many organizations.
So we compress the data.
We dedup the data.
And after an initial
synchronization, let's say,
from file to object
in the cloud,
any additional transfers will
only ship across the diffs.
So we try to be very
efficient there.
And CloudConnect is also
fully REST API-controllable.
So anything you can
do through our UIs,
you can do it
using REST as well.
And the key thing to think
about with CloudConnect
is this concept of a connection.
And this connection,
the connection
has a source and a target.
And in the case of going
from on-prem to the cloud,
your on-prem location is
going to be your source,
and your cloud bucket is
going to be your target.
So now, let's go back to
our use case example, so
our ElastiFizz.
We've got this amazing product.
We've got this commercial.
We're ready to scale
our infrastructure.
So as a starting
point, we've got
some new data for our
ElastiFizz campaign
that we've got on-premises.
And we want to get it
into the cloud, right?
To start off, we have a little
bit of data in the cloud,
as you can see here.
We've got a couple simple
Elastifile logos and stuff,
but we want to bring over
some of these new characters
and some additional logos to
get ready for this commercial
and the influx of visitors that
we're expecting to our website.
So we want to stage this data
and get it into the cloud.
So we're going to
use CloudConnect
to bring the data over from
our on-premises location
into GCP and into GCS.
And that's what we're
going to show here.
And it's a pretty
simple process.
Now the first thing
is, let's just
look at the state
of our environment.
So we go to our WordPress back
end and our media library.
And you can see, as I
mentioned, we've got one logo.
So it's pretty lonely there.
It's kind of poor.
So let's go into CloudConnect.
So we go to the Elastifile UI.
We're going to select
Google, of course.
And we're going to
call this an upload
connection, because we're taking
data from on-prem to the cloud.
Our bucket name is
going to be gcp-demo-1.
And in this case, if we go
to the Google Cloud back end,
just to show you, gcp-demo-1
doesn't currently exist.
That bucket has not
yet been created.
We're going to create it as part
of this process, automatically.
So we're going to select
a check-in connection,
and we're going to go ahead and
perform a check-in connection
creation operation here.
Now what we're doing
now is we're going here,
and we're going to grab
the source directory
from our on-premisis
environment that has the data
that we want to bring over.
So these are our additional
logos and files, et cetera.
So now we created
the connection.
And we're going to
move forward, and we're
going to actually
perform the check-in.
And we'll give it a
description of "version 1."
So when you go back
to the Google Cloud UI
after the check-in has
been created and performed,
we're going to refresh.
And you'll be able to
see, gcp-demo-1 has now
been created, right?
This bucket that didn't
exist is now available.
And if we click
into the bucket, you
can see it's full of objects.
These objects represent
the file system data
that was encoded leveraging
CloudConnect-- again, retaining
all the file and
directory hierarchy,
all the links, all the
attributes of that file system,
but stored in cheap and deep
object format, ready for you
to use.
So now we've got
our additional data
for our campaign staged
in GCS in the cloud.
So let's load it into the
Elastifile file system,
because we are going to run
our web services infrastructure
on top of Elastifile, right?
Just like we were
running it on-prem,
we're going to run
it using Kubernetes
in the cloud on
top of Elastifile
to extend our infrastructure.
So let's do that.
So you can see now, we're going
to create a download connection
to check the data out.
Again, we're going to
specify that same bucket,
because we're pulling
the data from gcp-demo-1.
And now our target is going to
actually be a file system that
corresponds to a persistent
volume claim that
was created using Elastifile's
storage provisioner, right?
So we connected into Kubernetes
with that storage provisioner
in our storage class.
So we're going to specify that
is going to be our target.
So we put that data in there.
And we're going to create
our check-out connection.
So with that connection
created, we're
gonig to actually
perform the check-out.
And here you can
see some options
for how you handle
files in a check-out,
if they were already
existing, et cetera.
So we'll pull the check-out.
That happens.
If we look in our
in-cloud file system,
you can see an image upload
directory has been created.
That wasn't there before.
And if you look, there's
several files in that directory.
So just to close
the story, we'll
go back to our media library.
We'll look.
OK, image upload directory,
that's the one that we just
created with our check-out
We're going to
select a few files,
pull them into our
media content library.
We'll take a look and
see what they are.
And there you can see it.
We got some additional logos.
We've got our cool
little characters.
So now we're ready, right?
Our website is now primed
with the additional content
that we want to leverage in
our scale-out infrastructure
to support the influx of
visitors from our commercial.
So that's great.
So we've got the data
in the file system.
Yep.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
JEROME MCFARLAND: So you can
use rsync to bring data across.
But with CloudConnect, you get
a lot of granular capabilities
to manage the lifecycle of
the data in that you can have
the data stored in an object
until you're ready to use it,
let's say.
And you can pull it out
into the file system.
When you're done with the data
and processing with the file
system, you can push
it back into object
and spin down the file system.
So CloudConnect gives you a
little bit more granularity
on how you manage the
lifecycle of data,
whether it's stored in
object or in file, right?
So again, we're trying to blend
the best of both worlds there.
rsync might be characterized
as one of those manual methods
to bring the data over
that I mentioned before
All right, so now we've got
the data in our file system.
So we're ready to go.
So let's just do a
little bit of work.
Before we do the work,
actually, let me come back
to the data mobility
piece and just
make sure we talk
about-- we close that.
So we've shown hybrid
cloud connectivity.
We've brought data from
on-prem into the cloud.
And we've shown the connectivity
between file and object.
And one thing I didn't
mention is that CloudConnect
is bidirectional, of course.
You know, I showed a flow
bringing data from on-prem
into object, and
then from object
into the file
system in the cloud.
You can also bring
data back, right?
You can bring it back into
object from the file system.
You can take it from object
back into your on-premisis
environment, if so desired.
So I think we've covered
the data mobility.
So let's just do a
little bit of work.
Let's make sure that everything
kind of fits together
and actually works properly.
So here, we've already got a
WordPress deployment spun out.
You can see one WordPress pod.
I also want to
highlight that we've
got this db loader pod here.
And what that's
doing is actually
generating synthetic
I/O reads and writes
on the back end of our
storage infrastructure
and just hitting the
Elastifile cluster
with some reads and writes.
So we want to make the
cluster work in addition
to the read commands
that are going
to be coming in through JMeter,
which is what we're spinning up
here, generating some workload
through our web infrastructure.
So we've got the web
workload, and we've also
got some back-end I/O. And
that will come into play later.
So you can see everything
seems to be working.
We're handling about 44,000
read requests per minute.
So we're able to handle
some traffic to our website.
So that's interesting.
But really, with Kubernetes,
what you want to be able to do
is leverage the
scalability, right?
So let's scale the
front end, right?
Let's get some additional
WordPress front-end pods
going here in our
GKE deployment.
So that's what we're
going to do next.
So here you can see, got
the initial WordPress pod
that's there.
So we're going to scale to
four replicas using kubectl.
We'll do that.
You'll be able to see
there's now four WordPress
replicas up and running.
So we scaled our front end.
And you're going to see the
performance is going to scale
up of our cluster, as well.
So we went from
around 45, and we're
going to scale up to about
70,000 requests handled
per minute.
Now of course,
scaling the front end
is only one piece of the story.
And Kubernetes provide
seamless capability to do that,
as we just discussed.
Scaling the back end
and scaling the storage
can also be an important
part of the story.
What if you need
additional capacity?
What if storage has become the
bottleneck to the performance
for your given application?
So you need more
scale-our performance.
So of course, with Elastifile,
as I mentioned previously,
you can scale the
file system as well.
So we're going to show you,
quickly, how to do that
as well to control all parts
of your infrastructure.
So as I mentioned before,
we had that one db loader
that was running and
generating some synthetic I/O
on the back end.
So before we scale
our cluster, we're
going to scale that db loader.
So you can see we've now created
four replicas for that db
loader.
So we're increasing
the amount of I/O
that's hitting our file system.
And the reason that we do
that is because we wanted
to be able to show, in the
performance UI for Elastifile,
you can see the performance of
the cluster scaling up, right?
In conjunction with that
additional I/O that's
being hit, we can see the
additional performance growth
there in the UI, all
while actually maintaining
a fairly low latency
under 2 milliseconds.
So you're able to
see the ability
to monitor the performance
as your environment workload
changes.
So now let's actually
add some capacity.
So here we're going
back to that same UI.
I'm going to add 3 terabytes
of the type of storage
I've selected.
So in this case, that's going
to correspond to spinning up
one additional node.
So as we saw before,
that's happening
in the back end on GCP.
We're spinning up that
additional infrastructure
to supply that
additional storage.
So you'll be able to see
now, that node is now
active and available
in our cluster--
or it's ready to
deploy in our cluster.
And we're going to
deploy it, and that's
going to make it active.
So once we hit Deploy, now
seamlessly, in the background,
that additional capacity is
being added into our cluster.
You don't need to take
any additional actions.
Your cluster
performance and capacity
are going to extend with
those additional resources
seamlessly, simply by
deploying it and adding it.
And as you saw there,
it's now active.
And now we have four storage
nodes in our cluster,
giving us additional capacity
and additional performance.
So we've actually done quite
a few things here, right?
We started with some
data on-premises
that we wanted to
get into the cloud.
We spun up the Elastifile
file system seamlessly.
So we had that storage
capacity available there.
We pushed the data over
into object storage.
We decided, OK, we're ready
to load the file system,
so we pulled the data out of
object into the file system.
We scaled our WordPress
infrastructure.
And then we scaled our
storage infrastructure.
So we've done quite a few things
in this kind of simple use case
example.
But really, storage and data
management for Kubernetes
are not topics that only
relate to web services.
They relate to a much broader
range of applications and use
cases.
And with that in mind, I'll
now hand over to Katreena
from HudsonAlpha,
who's going to take you
through a different use case
in the scientific computing
domain.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] ?
JEROME MCFARLAND: Not
in this example, no.
But you can use stateful sess
in conjunction with this.
KATREENA MULLICAN: All
right, think you, Jerome.
It's great to be here.
Hi, everyone.
I am Katreena Mullican,
technology director and cloud
whisperer at HudsonAlpha.
HudsonAlpha Institute
for Biotechnology
is a nonprofit genomic and
genetic research institute
located in Huntsville, Alabama.
We leverage the power of
the human genome sequence
to better understand
causes and early indicators
for complex diseases, such
as cancer and Alzheimer's,
and the genetic causes of
rare and undiagnosed diseases
as well.
We are a genomic
sequencing leading facility
in the world for human health as
well as agriscience endeavors.
Researchers, entrepreneurs,
and educators
collaborate with each other
and over 40 associate companies
located on our 160-acre
campus in Huntsville.
Our education program provides
on-prem and virtual curriculum
for adults and students, their
teachers, and lifelong learners
around the world.
And HudsonAlpha's also home to
the first standalone genomic
medicine clinic which uses
genome sequencing data
to provide patient diagnoses.
So that's a little
bit about HudsonAlpha.
One of the great things
about HudsonAlpha
is our ability to rapidly
adopt emerging technologies.
And to do this, we, in IT,
have a devops mentality
and treat
infrastructure as code.
So our on-prem,
composable infrastructure
provides the backbone for
a variety of use cases,
including the one shown here,
which is an on-prem Kubernetes
cluster built on bare metal.
The Kubernetes master
and several worker nodes
are provisioned using
open-source tools,
such as CentOS, and Python,
and HashiCorp Consul.
Consul provides
service discovery.
And Datadog, which is a
cloud-hosted monitoring
service, provides information
about our uptime and monitoring
application and
infrastructure performance.
So what we're going
to do today is
talk about the power
of provisioning
this on-prem Kubernetes
cluster as code
and then show why and how
it can become a hybrid cloud
Kubernetes cluster by
extending onto GCP.
So first, let's take a look
at the process of provisioning
this on-prem cluster.
[LAUGHS] That's really tall.
OK.
So here, you'll see some Python.
So this is just a way to provide
configuration for the master
and worker nodes here.
You can see things
like enclosure numbers,
bay numbers, template names.
These are all custom
attributes that
are read by scripts that
work as the nodes come up
for the first time and provide
a personalization experience.
So the nodes know their role,
what they're supposed to do.
Consul plays in here also.
The roles can read
key-value pairs
and write key-value pairs.
So awareness of other nodes
happens through this process.
There's a simple, common
provisioning script
that is used for all
of our use cases.
You'll see it makes a connection
to OneView, in this case,
for our composable
infrastructure.
It parses the configuration
from the master and the worker
files, creates server profiles,
sets custom attributes
that will be read by
those startup scripts.
And so the whole point
here is, one line of code,
and the environment's
provisioned.
You write this script one time.
You check it in to
version control.
And this speaks highly
to accuracy and speed
of delivering the resources.
So with this one line right
here, I'm going to go ahead
and provision a
Kubernetes master node.
All right, it's already
starting to come up.
So let's take a look at Consul.
Consul runs as a
Docker container--
see, right here.
So in addition to
key-value pairs,
it also provide service
discovery, and IP address host
name, and status of
every member that
talks to this Consul server.
So right now, I
just have myself.
But as things are
provisioned, this
is a one-stop shop for me
to come type this command,
see what's in my environment,
and be able to connect to it.
All right, looks like
this one just powered on.
That's the master.
So we're going to
rerun this same script,
but this time create a worker.
And I can repeat this for
as many resources as I have.
I can keep coming
up with workers.
And we do, of course,
have multiple workers
in our cluster.
So we're waiting
for that to come up.
I'm going to go back
to Consul and actually
check on things here, see
if the master is showing up.
Looks like the
worker just came on.
There's our master.
And we'll see the
worker in a moment.
So one of the things
that the automation does
is it embeds SSH keys,
which allows me to do
a passwordless connection.
As soon as the node's
up, as soon as I verify
it's up with Consul, I can
do a passwordless connection
into the Kubernetes master.
So remember, the
only thing I've typed
is a Python script
with an argument.
I mean, I have not done any
Kubernetes setup at this point.
This is all automagic part
of the provisioning scripts.
So here we come into
the Kubernetes master.
You're going to do some
sanity checks to see
if it knows about the nodes.
And it knows about the master.
It looks like the worker--
it's been 20 seconds--
it's not quite ready.
So I'm going to give it
just another couple seconds
and check back.
There it is.
Another thing that the automatic
scripts do in this case
is they embed Datadog
monitoring as a daemon set.
So that's the next thing
I'm going to check on
is to see if this happened.
It'll automatically deploy a
daemon set per worker node.
And of course, Datadog was--
like I mentioned, it's
used for monitoring
of uptime and performance.
So we see we do have a Datadog
agent running on our worker.
So what I'm going to do, just
for the purpose of this demo,
is just an nginx
deployment to show you--
we're going to start
with three replicas,
so I can scale it up
later and see how this
works in just a little bit.
So starting with three,
just your typical nginx--
this is sanity checking
for the environment
to make sure that my
cluster and API are working.
All right.
And just as we expect, we
have containers creating.
And there's our pods.
So, so far, so good.
So this is all
on-prem, bare metal,
Kubernetes provisioned as code
on composable infrastructure
at HudsonAlpha.
And as a final check,
we'll just check on Datadog
while we're at it.
Yes, those daemon
sets are running,
so I should have my
master and worker.
And I should be
starting to gather--
it just is now coming
up, but starting
to gather these metrics.
But so what if the on-prem
environment is not enough?
You know, genomics takes a
tremendous amount of data.
We generate about five
petabytes of data each year.
And one of the tricks
with running in-cloud
is, how do you get your
data into the cloud?
So as Jerome
mentioned, Elastifile
is helping us do that.
The amount of compute
can sometimes not
be sufficient in your
on-prem environment either.
So let me just give you
a genomic sequencing 101.
When DNA and genomes
are sequenced,
that's represented as data.
So you take the data
from a sequence subject,
you compare it to what we
call a reference genome.
And the process of
figuring out all
of the differences between
you and a reference genome
is known as variant calling.
It's a very
compute-intensive process.
Requires a lot of
scratch space and a lot
of demand on your resources.
And it's accomplished
through a set of--
what we call a
pipeline, a set of tools
that execute in a certain order.
What happens, though, is that
new versions of the pipeline
become available.
So we size our data center to
handle the day-to-day, 24/7
variant calling, right?
But then when these
new versions come out,
researchers want to go back.
In addition to the
day-to-day workload,
they want to go back
and reanalyze everything
with the new version.
Because they might glean
some new knowledge,
because this new
version has come out.
So in that case, your
computer requirements
are definitely stressed
beyond their normal workload.
The good news is that
tools and pipelines
are becoming containerized.
And therefore, a
great solution--
and this is what I set
out to do at HudsonAlpha--
was to figure out how to
burst our on-prem Kubernetes
solution into public cloud.
And part of what
makes that possible
is things like a direct
connect, VPN to public cloud.
There are ways to
connect the networks,
but you also have to worry
about connecting the storage.
So the on-prem worker nodes
access the on-prem data.
The cloud worker nodes
access the cloud data.
So for us, that's a
matter of deploying
Elastifile in the cloud
and CloudConnect on-prem.
I'll show a graphic
in just a moment.
But that was the next
hurdle to overcome
is, how are we going to get the
appropriate data into the cloud
so that these worker
nodes can chew on that?
The good news is Consul.
And then what I'm using
for service discovery
can communicate with
everybody because
of that network, the private
networking setup between us
and the cloud.
And then, of course,
your workload
could be manually
scaled, or ideally,
auto-scaled as soon as those
resources become available.
So this is how this looks.
On the left is
Huntsville, Alabama.
Here's our on-prem
compute that we just
talked about with the
master and workers.
So I showed how easy
that is to spin up.
Existing NAS or
Elastifile on-prem
can work with the
CloudConnect node.
So CloudConnect knows
about our existing data.
CloudConnect, as Jerome
showed, pushes the data up
to GCS cloud storage.
And then over in Google land, we
can push up as many Kubernetes
workers as we'd like.
And they all have
access to that data.
So the workers at the
bottom here, the tool set,
is very similar, except
I'm going with Terraform
for my provisioning in public
cloud instead of Python,
and we've added Elastifile,
of course, to the mix.
So let's take a look.
This is my Terraform.
So it's pretty
standard stuff-- just
define a Google Cloud provider.
There's a few variables.
Of course, at your
discretion, you
can choose as many variables as
you'd like for the environment.
This just shows some of
the ones I'm using here.
And one of the big
differences here
to accomplish the
automation is that there's
a scripts and a service
files directory.
The scripts consist of the--
they're Bash scripts, but they
start up all of the application
that we need to and
all of the automation.
And then the service
files are systemd files.
So it really is as simple
as telling Terraform
that we want--
in this case, I
just chose a number,
so we're going to say three--
purely vanilla CentOS 7.
There's nothing special
about that CentOS 7,
and that's on purpose.
I'm a big believer
that you don't
put the magic into
the image, you
put the magic into the code.
So scripts and service
file directories
are going to be copied up.
And then these are
commands that are
going to be executed
automatically
on each node as they boot.
Some of this is to mount
Elastifile NFS in fstab,
to set up my DNS for Elastifile
and to mount that directory.
So at this point, I've
written the code, pushed it up
to version control.
I'm going to do a sanity
check here with Terraform.
And if everything looks
good, go ahead and apply it.
And we're going to watch this
thing come to life in Google.
And then it will
automatically associate itself
with my on-prem, bare
metal Kubernetes cluster.
And this is real-time here.
[LAUGHS] So from the
moment I type "yes,"
I can immediately
go check out GCP.
Do a refresh, and
they're coming.
Here's the three nodes, of
course, that I asked for.
Go back and shave a
little bit of time off.
It's been 2 minutes
and 40 seconds.
Everybody's up.
And my favorite command--
are they here?
Yes.
I not only have my on-prem
bare metal Kubernetes cluster,
I've got the three
new worker nodes.
I've got their IPs,
I've got their status,
so we're good to go.
I can connect into one of
these, if I want to for sanity.
I don't have to.
I can say, let's
connect to it once.
Let's just make sure
the scripts work.
Let's make sure
my data is there.
So we're going to
pick the first guy.
We're going to connect to
him and just do a simple df,
and looking for this line.
So he's mounted up.
And at that point, this node
can consume that directory
as it needs to, if the
app's running on there.
So we exit back.
We're going to repeat the
ssh to our worker node--
I'm sorry, our master node.
And I'm going to ask
it to get the nodes.
We're going to see
if everybody's here.
Yep.
So I've got my
three GCP workers.
They're good to go.
And I'm going to do a
sanity check on Datadog,
make sure the daemon set's
functioning as it should across
to the cloud.
I should have one-- yep, I have
one per GCP node over there.
And then as a final
demonstration,
instead of auto-scaling it, I'm
just going to force my nginx
deployment to go to, like, 30--
pick a nice number now that
I've got some more compute.
Yep, I've got three that
I asked for initially.
We're going to scale that up.
Sorry about the typing.
I guess I was a little tired.
I don't know.
It's kind of slow.
I'm working on it.
OK.
All right, scaled it up.
And repeat the pods,
just to show, yeah,
everybody's at the party now.
We've got on-prem
from the bare metal.
We've got the GCP nodes.
And each of these can
be scaled independently
based on which script
you're executing.
If you want more on-prem,
you do the Python.
If you want more in the
cloud, you do the Terraform.
But it's all code.
It works every time.
And it's repeatable
at this point.
You don't have to waste a lot
of time with sanity checks
anymore, because
you know it's going
to be the same every time.
So here's Datadog.
They've checked in,
and I'm starting
to gather metrics
on those already.
So that's a successful
scaled Kubernetes cluster
with my on-prem
environment as one
of the clouds, my private cloud,
right, and then GCP public.
So I'll give it back to you.
JEROME MCFARLAND:
Thanks, Katreena.
Really cool stuff
to see those types
of workflows in action
for real-world use cases,
especially in domains
like life sciences
that can benefit so many of us.
Just a couple of final
thoughts or things
that we want to
leave you with here--
so if you remember
anything, what
we'd like you to really remember
is that you have the capability
to leverage Kubernetes
stateful services
to package, scale, and mobilize
a broad variety of applications
and workflows.
Again, like I
mentioned before, it's
no longer the sole domain of
microservices and stateless
applications.
You can leverage
Kubernetes for much,
much more, including
applications
that need to persist, and
manage, and mobilize data.
We encourage you to evaluate
your storage options
very carefully.
You have lots of
options with Kubernetes,
but make sure that you're really
considering the key selection
criteria for your workflows
around usability, scalability,
shareability, and data
mobility to make sure
that you have a solution
that can provide all
the needs that
you're going to have,
both today and in the future.
And finally, of course,
as we've been mentioning,
we have a turn-key solution
available from Elastifile
through the GCP Marketplace,
both for the file system,
as well as the
storage provisioner
for the connectivity
into Kubernetes.
And I also want to give a
special thanks to Ronen Cohen,
one of my collaborators
at Elastifile, who
helped develop all the
demos that you saw today.
And finally, if you want to
learn more about Elastifile,
we're here in the south hall
of Moscone in Booth S1503.
So we've got all the experts
from our teams are here.
We can talk about
pretty much any angle
of these types of solutions
that you want to go through.
So I want to encourage you
to visit us and learn more.
[MUSIC PLAYING]